the jurogan experience even back then i
saw where change was trying to take
place in the industry and they wasn't
going
allow i call it a conspiracy i saw the
conspiracy taking place where they
wasn't going to allow any more
masterpiece cash money uh
uh irv guidance independence yeah
independence they was like
shedding that door yeah so you know in
my mind i'm like
okay i see the move they make and let me
counter
this and create another avenue for the
youth to come in after us
and unfortunately i think uh
they witnessed the same thing and they
hit murder inc
which is herb gotti company destroyed it
they hit suge knight death row we know
what happened with that
and they came at me in a massive way
you know all the way up to the point
where they put a man on me that killed
eight people and i really believe you
know
he was trying to kill me and when you
say they put a man on you
like in what way they assigned
a guy by the name of schumacher you know
on me to arrest me to
whatever he was supposed to do but
he sent death threats at me and here's a
man
that killed eight people you know i
hired investigators since they was
investigating me i decided to hire an
investigator
to investigate them and that's when i
found out
this guy killed all of those people you
know i brought the investigating report
so you can look at it if you choose yeah
you showed me outside yeah yeah
so you know this was a real life
situation that
people may hear and think you know
this is not true but here's confirmation
of how true it was
in 1999 you know i reported this with
the help
of congresswoman maxine waters janet
reno
because they intervened on my behalf
because
they saw what was happening and of
course we they had a uh
what you call that a congressional
hearing
on me all of this is public information
a congressional hearing
where the dea and you know it reminded
me of the time
when clarence thomas was uh
being uh a hearing was taking place over
his harassment or something
and all of those people democrat
and republicans was around you know what
i mean had him in a circle
so this is the conversation they was
having concerning me
james prince and i'm watching this you
know on uh
on video i'm not invited but i'm
watching them have this conversation
about me
about the congressional hearing and uh
i'm just like wow
you know these people want me pretty bad
but a long story short you know
they were able to speak up on my behalf
and
you know which ultimately or so many
connections
to this because even al gore you know
came in a portrait where they
tried to set me up at my church with al
gore
al gore came to visit my church you know
which when you're running for
president you visit a lot of black
churches and stuff like that
and my pastor wanted me to meet al gore
that day
so when i pull up you know i was married
at the time
you know i told my wife i say
all these people ain't here with the
president because i was watching body
language
you know i saw black black glasses kind
of look in my direction and
she said oh come on boy you being leery
you know then people are not thinking
about you or whatever
so i went and heard the sermon and
before the sermon was over
i say let's go normally i hang around
and socialize and of course
pastor wanted me to meet al gore i
decided to leave
and shortly after the dallas
newspaper came out with a a story
and all of this you can confirm and look
it up
james prince donated a quarter million
dollars
to al gore at the church to stop
an investigation on him oh man just a
bunch of bs unbelievable
you know what i mean so i was being set
up news oh yeah
it's documented so they created this
fake story
to make you look bad mm-hmm and they
printed it in the news so it had to be
coordinated
at the very top oh yeah wow
yeah what was that like to know they
were conspiring against you like that
you know first of all you had to feel
like oh [ __ ] i must have [ __ ] made it
well i didn't quite feel
that i had made it i felt like they
wanted to hit me
yeah you know because like these this
guy
one night i left my office and
a dps officer stopped me
he got behind me on the streets when i
left out of the office
but he stopped me on the freeway and it
was the first time i would stop one time
to be told to go and stop again
so he stopped me on the freeway and told
me to go and
pull in the mcdonald's parking lot
so i say oh okay so as i
exit the freeway and looked over in the
mcdonald's parking lot it was dark
and i saw a carrot a cherry key jeep
green and a cutlass and it was dark
so i'm like nah i'm not pulling in that
dog so i
kind of told him i'm gonna pull in the
shell station where the lights were
so um and i could hear him in the back
pull [ __ ] over
on this on his thing make a right i'm
like i'm gonna go over here
so i went over there in the light i had
some guys behind me following me because
they had been sending me threats so i'm
not stupid so i understood that
you know i need to cover myself until i
make it home
and uh when i pull over you know the
officer got out
and he said why you didn't pull over
like i told you
i say sir i didn't want you to think i
was trying to hurt you in that dog
and i didn't want to think you was
trying to hurt me what's the problem
ah well you were swerving
i said no i say you got the wrong man i
don't drink i don't smoke
what no swerving going on with me well
uh
where are your guns right
how do he even know i have guns i gave
him my gun lights and i say well how you
know i have guns i haven't even given
you my license
so i i gave you my license i say my
hands on the steering wheel
my guns are under my seat well well get
out the car get out and say okay i don't
have a problem with that
how much money you have i say
you want to borrow some money or
something why you ask me about my money
so he told me to go in the back of the
car so i went back there
and uh he went
and searched in my car you know he in
there i see him
like moving around with things but he
went on the passenger side
so i walk around i say man why are you
violating my right searching my car
and he jumped get back i'm looking for
the gun i said
i told you where the guns are clearly
you then pass them up you got my clips
out
so anyway he came back and i could see
him making eye contact
with the car with the people across the
street and eventually
one of them drove over and
this was an officer by the name of chad
scott
he had like black paint on his eyes
in an army fatigue type of a uniform
and him and officer you know
translated some words and he came back
to me and said okay you free to go and
gave me a warning ticket
you know a warning ticket and
it was then when i got home i realized
a bullet or two was missing so red flags
like
oh [ __ ] yeah like one up i'm like damn
why would they keep one of my bullets
why were they trying to pull me in the
dark this was before
i knew you know schumacher had killed
eight people
you know what i mean so you know i went
home and that really caused me to uh
you know want to protect myself and want
to document
why i wanted to protect myself so
bizarre that they would take bullets too
because without the rifling from your
particular gun
like all it's establishing is the same
round you use
right it doesn't mean anything yeah i
didn't know it's weird
you know i just counted them and i'm
like when you said that they were
threatening you like death threats like
what kind of death
how are you receiving these what they
were doing
and it's an investigative report people
that worked for me
you know i had a street team that would
promote my records in different clubs
at night what they had done
was jumped on a couple guys they pulled
them over
they took them down to the station
stripped them naked
you know jumped on them took their
jewelry you know all kinds of stuff and
send messages
let him know you know we're going to do
this we're going to do this
which eventually when i made my report
they end up finding the jury in
different things
that i reported that you know god told
them these guys
you got rolled cops i said y'all put a
hit man on me
you got two road cops that's doing this
and doing that and i'm in fear of my
life
you know i just wanted to be known
because if a situation takes place and i
come out on top
then i don't want nobody to be mad at me
right
because i'm gonna protect myself yeah
yeah
how long did this period of turmoil last
because it seemed like that would be
incredibly stressful well
it went on for years years you know yeah
even before the end they stopped me one
night
and they they planted a appeal on me
called
ecstasy you know and how where'd they
put it
they put it here's what happened i was
in the back seat first of all the police
stopped me
and this was the officer i had a run in
with with a pistol case and i beat the
pistol case
so he stopped me on uh richmond one
night and he was like
well how did you beat that case and he
knew it was me because i had rap light
on my license plate
how did you be i said man i don't really
want to talk about that i said i'm
trying
to go to a party you know why are you
stopping me
so it made me get out put me in the back
of the police car
kept me there you know talking to people
for you know quite
a long time and he decided to take me
off the main street
to a side street and it was then where
he took me out of
one car and took me to another car
with two more younger rookie officers
and shortly after he came out with a
pill
in the back of the first car look what
we have here
and i'm like you know when i seen that
taking place
i said to the two officers i say man i
say i've been in here y'all know
he's now you're not trying to do that
that's not look what we have here look
what we have here
and before i know it i was headed to the
police station
and they charged me with a pill called
ecstasy
and i immediately got out of jail
took a test a drug test took a lot of
take to test just to prove
you know i had nothing to do with any of
that so they tried to get me to cop
out for probation and cop-out i'm like
no
so the peel changed from exit
ecstasy to drent tranzact whatever that
field is
and it changed again it was constantly
changing as they test
the pill and they was basically trying
to get me to cop out for something
and i wouldn't and eventually the case
was dismissed
so how many years did all this go on for
you said it went on for years how many
years
i would say 10 years 10 [ __ ] years 10
years or better i was a target how did
you stay calm during that time because
that's got to be incredibly stressful
yeah it was you know because like
in the hood where i'm from you have to
uh
survive the guys that's in the hood
because they trying to get you
you know wherever success is concerned
they trying to get you
and the police that's supposed to be
protecting me
the ones i'm paying all these taxes to
have became
uh uh a enemy where they was trying to
get me
so it it was very stressful but
after so long i became immune to it it's
almost like you know
i had a made-up mind because i was on a
journey to break the poverty curse
where my family was concerned that was
my whole drive
i'm like i got to get my mother this
house that she always wanted you know i
come from the projects
so i was dealing with a power that was
greater than the powers from
the streets and from the police and
i was like you know no weapon form
against me going to prosper
so you know i had that mentality i
wrapped it around spirituality
and you know i said god be for me the
world could be against me
and you know it just became like a
lifestyle dealing with them people catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience